ganz deutschland hallo erstmal meine
damen und herren ist er wieder im keller
ist die bag am start mit vier produkten
ich war nicht enttäuscht
mithin unterwegs cool füllen wir haben
hier produkte gekauft und zwar einmal
den slums in ingelheim dann haben wir
den slider megawatt strom noisy ende
wohl dann haben wir das produkt den
islamismus formula rossa schweiz und als
allerletztes haben wir den ups wittwer
slam matches afe und der wurst und
scheint also ich schau mal was diese
können mit welchem produkt seiner anfang
als summa summarum look zeigen
da die mehrheit wollte dass er mit dem
pinken islam anfangen würde sagen packen
wir nochmal als erstes aus ich weiß aber
ich hab's ja solche verpackungen ich
weiß allerdings nicht was dieser sei
jetzt genau kann also an es stets
zumindest darauf dass das
niedergelassener schleimt ist der staat
laut vor allem laut und bauen also
frechheit er bereits freunde seid ihr
beiden bereits heute bereit ja denn
liegt das wird kein shampoo fordert
ratings wurde in dieses ding da
reinpassen
genau kann also wir haben jetzt hier auf
jeden fall diesen als launisch sein und
er steht da da steht es ja mega
elastisch ist also ich weiß nämlich dass
sie ihnen die aufmachen muss oder ob ich
denn hier so gehen wir aus
es gab vor ein paar monaten diese trends
immer auf youtube die voll waren mit
schleim videos wo die gesagt haben dort
die fast
also wenn märklin kompletten slime aus
dieser kleine box herausgenommen und
freunde der also ich weiß nicht ob das
ich hatte auch mal so ein schreiben der
bahn an diesem juni und wenn man jetzt
auf dem boden schmeißt er dann
gesprungen ist also mal schauen ob das
klappt ja jetzt nicht mit es jetzt mal
die elastizität und zwar wird hier
gezeigt dass er die komplett auseinander
ich habe hier auch noch ein bisschen
schnell deshalb meine pizza also der
fast bislang irgendwie so an und zieht
ihm wirklich so auseinander darf alter
schwede das ist
nein das riecht nach zu schreiben
da stimmen alle meine damen und herren
dass sie weit das erste produkt was uns
angeschaut haben das ist ein mega
elastischer schlagen die sache ist hier
steht es tom neu sie ein megabyte wo ist
der neue macht irgendwas in welche
geräusche
nein du kriegst sie nicht ja komm okay
du ihn dir weniger da das produkt nummer
eins war meine damen und herrn will ich
sagen widmen wir uns jetzt den kloß und
der voll angeblich irgendwie vor zu
können schließlich auch ich weiß nicht
warum man das man so krank kontakt weil
das ist ja einfach nur umwelt
verschmutzen mit dem letzten platz und
keine geil alter von 73 jahren
also wer jetzt hier auf jeden fall
diesen toiletten schlagen der ein
bisschen der halt irgendwie putzen soll
also ich weiß jetzt nicht nicht dass
hier ein schneiden durch den schlamm
durch oder war ich genauso was ich
diesen schlecht lassen musste er kommt
sehr gut aus der verpackung aus also das
jetzt nicht irgendwie zermatt oder keine
ahnung was hier steht jetzt allerdings
ist dieser schleim sich so an werden
soll als wenn keiner gehört
[Gelächter]
was wenn ich so richtig doll lieb
[Applaus]
[Musik]
damit könnte ich mich den ganzen tag
beschäftigen thermisch menschen gesehen
ziemlich abstoßen ja meine damen und
herren wir kommen jetzt zum dritten
produkt juli noch immer das dritte
produkt ist der sly die singing and
glory schleimt also wir werden auch hier
wieder die verpackung ordnungsgemäß auf
machen hier weil es mir wichtig dass
schlag in die fresse der könige furzt
hatte hatte gerade die erkenntnis dass
eventuell sogar der pink ist hier drin
vorziehen würde wir stehen auf mich
alter weil es ja einfach nur dieses
gefährt ist und wenn man ihn vielleicht
ein bisschen zusammendrückt also mal
abwarten ob dieser sein eventuell auch
alter passen fake das war das
ekelhafteste was ich je im gesicht hatte
also wir können sagen freut ihr euch
dieses leinkauf könnt ihr euch auch
normal einkaufen und den linken glas
füllen oder so dann werden die
wahrscheinlich auch in die kurzen aber
lass die mal waren die mit dem grünen
slime von richtig beschissen idee also
das ist bisher diese schleim situation
nicht wir gerade haben aber jetzt haben
wir hier die neuen blauen stein
erleuchtet und macht musik
und eigentlich müsst ihr euch noch
einmal ausleihen kaufen den rest könnt
ihr mit allen anderen punkten auf machen
halter warum ist ja denn so hat ekelhaft
oder das ist jetzt anscheinend so neues
land fühlt sich auch schon komplett
anders an der 40 ein bisschen
hochwertige an aber auch ein bisschen
ekelhafter also der street parade eine
komische farbe gerade das ist jetzt der
vorherigen kiesow und pink grün
der sieht jetzt auch erwin winkel also
das kleinhirn leuchtet jetzt im dunkel
ich weiß nicht wie wir das aus bin aber
ich würde sagen ich hastig gegessen
alter der islam ist halt echt noch mal
ein bisschen anders er ist ein bisschen
egal wie heißt das geld wahrscheinlich
alle schon mal irgendwie slime mit zu
hause dem das volk für die youtuber
gemacht aber ich mache dass ich spiele
will ich zum ersten mal mit seinem style
und das ist ja todes geil
du kriegst ihn nicht also dieser soll
angeblich im dunkeln leuchten ich würde
sagen dass es mir egal
am ende des videos jetzt erst mal hier
sind nämlich ein bisschen heller
seit juli seien dorthin kommen wir nun
zum letzten produkt und zwar dem chorus
line hier steht enge in der krise das
ist aber das stetige entdeckt im schleim
ich rede also das hier ist jetzt das
letzte produkt was ich mir irgendwie
auch gebraucht habe das irgendwie so ein
horror schleim
er hat auf jeden war alter ich habe
kraft vergessen dass die insekten drin
waren und dann ist das eine ekelhafte
spinne ja auf jeden fall die gleiche
konsistenz wie ich meine
ist ja schön und gut dass er irgendwie
auch ein dunkel leute da war mit den
insekten deshalb mega eklat
diese waren noch größere also hier sind
irgendwelche spinnen drin irgendeinen
hier irgend eine spinne mit dem gericht
gar nicht umspielen jeden fall ist in
diesem schleimhäute vorne so ekelhaft
komische spinnen drin ich will mit
diesem schlag bisschen locker wenn wir
den ganzen schweiß mein blut community
ausgleich auf rund bei jetzt habe ich
eine spinne angefasst also die produkte
waren jetzt dieser komische roxheim der
haft ist anstelle von wirklich sonst
gingen in die fresse
[Musik]
man reicht es nur grundstoff spinnen
sind aber auch dass es ein fachartikel
wir haben jetzt hier auf jeden fall vier
produkte gekauft und ausprobieren einmal
dieser ganz normale schleimen diese
lieder eine schlange dann der popel
schleimen dann hatten wir noch hier
vorne den eine wasser dass hier das wäre
vor zu den wurzeln ins heim dann hatten
wir hier noch diesen horror slime mit
den komischen spinnen drin und dann
haben wir noch hier den slum der
angeblich im dunkeln leuchten soll bald
gibt es überdies neue klamotten im
fenster von de bevor wir jetzt in den
dunklen raum rein gehen werde ich noch
mal eben den islam ist ein bisschen mit
meinem handy lichter an leuchten ich
weiß nicht ob das jetzt gerade noch von
der sonne hier bin ich bin halt der
islam wird jetzt noch ein bisschen
angeleuchtet also mal schauen ob er
jetzt gleich im dunkeln leuchten wir
also filme mit rheinmetall so das ist
wirklich der raum hinter meinem
fernsehen sind so clay sie spiele apple
ich frage mich seit wochen noch um ein
weder nicht so gut sind das bild die
ganze zeit jo-jo das geil
das hat wirklich geil guck mal wie hatte
ich möchte jetzt gegen davos ist sie auf
jeden fall vom video wie bereits gesagt
wollte ich einfach mal im supermarkt
gehen und wieso 34 verschiedene sly
raten kaufen weil ich noch nie wirklich
ein video mit seinem gemacht habe wenn
es euch gefallen hat
eventuelle sagen würdet ihr doch mal 50
millionen liter schlamm macht darin dass
jetzt leider schreibt mir dass uns in
die kommentare und jetzt